is there anything redeeming about that
character I don't know anything about
her because is it like you know my only
frame of reference is like Walter White
was like horrible horrible person but
still you all root for him well I hope
that that's what I was able to achieve
you know because that in my mind that's
what I always was hoping that it was it
was such a horrific character of but you
don't want a horrific character nobody's
going to fall in love with a horrific
character so I always kept in my mind
that character wter for example or Tony
sopran or you know one of those
characters that are doing super horrible
things but there's something about them
so I hope that I but she did that for
survival that was like you when you were
talking about your upbringing and you
said that's part of the culture that was
her culture I don't know why and he was
a woman and in that time women didn't
have you know the power or the strength
to do those kind of things the things
that she did she even though they were
bad she did them better than any man and
so there's something in interesting
about that that it was interesting to me
I hope that everybody likes it I think
they're going to like it and I think
they're going to All tune in and they're
going to be I think that's a real Buzzy
thing to see especially from you for
whatever that I think that that's such a
different image than you've been
portraying your entire career that
that's exciting to see too and then on
top of that it's a really interesting
story that people are really interested
yeah it's super interesting and I also
for me it was amazing cuz got to work
for the first time with like Latin
people actually like to act with Latin
people what do you think of Latin
people so it was great the director Andy
VI was uh Colombian so that was amazing
for me because I was able to you know uh
communicate with him in Spanish so it
was so much easier and he was such a
great director like he we first became
friends at before starting the
production so it was very easy for me to
understand what he wanted to see what he
was coming I I had the best time it was
super hard but it was but I also know I
know I know for a fact that you are a
brilliant
actor